all right welcome back everybody okay so
I have posted homework five and I've
decided to give a little bit of an
extension on this homework because I
want to include stuff that I'm gonna
talk about all throughout next week
Monday Wednesday and Friday lectures so
it's gonna be due on Monday November
24th before it was due on Friday the
21st so this is just like the extra
weekend and Monday this is the Monday
before Thanksgiving and there won't be
any class because I'll be out of town
that day okay so this homework I think
that first parts are pretty
straightforward so you're kind of
showing some of these vector identities
like a cross B is orthogonal to a and B
and you're showing that the divergence
of a curl of a vector field is zero okay
those should be pretty straightforward
by hands then we're doing some volume
integration of some function we're gonna
find the area or the volume under this
function and we're gonna find the flux
of a vector field out of that region so
we're gonna use divergence theorem which
will probably cover on the Monday
lecture okay the fourth problem is a
little bit it's I wouldn't say it's
difficult but it's really important so I
told you that we wouldn't talk about
infinite dimensional function spaces
until after Christmas and I apologize
but I lied it's so important so I'm
gonna bring this up again in any 565
we're gonna start from scratch and
really derive Fourier transforms for
partial differential equations but I
want to get this idea kind of working in
the background of your brain earlier
okay
so what we're gonna think about our
inner product spaces which are vector
spaces that have an inner product okay
so probably next Wednesday or third or
Friday I'll tell you more about inner
products and vector spaces and what that
means but in this homework problem for
we're going to show that the space of
bounded functions that
defined on the interval from x equals 0
to x equals 1 define an inner product
space where the inner product is the
integral of F times G if this seems a
little strange that we're defining
functions as living in a vector space it
is strange it's a very strange but
important concept where functions live
in a vector space called Hilbert space
it's a vector space with infinitely many
dimensions so unlike XY and Z you can
kind of add dimensions to this vector
space of functions forever and we're
going to show that if you take cosine
functions so cosine of pi times some
integer X then that defines kind of a
basis direction in this function
function space this is not actually a
super hard homework problem all of the
steps are pretty straightforward but I
want you to start thinking about kind of
what it means for a function to be an
element of a vector space and what does
it mean for a basis element in that
vector space so this will all become a
little bit more clear next week ok any
questions about the homework of the
extensions or anything ok ok this is
gonna be really really important when we
start solving partial differential
equations we're gonna be thinking about
these functions and we're gonna be
thinking about differential operators on
this vector space of functions ok and so
that's what I'm going to talk to you
about today our differential operators
on vector spaces which is just a fancy
way of saying we're going to talk about
vector calculus ok so usually vector
calculus is one of the favorite subjects
of students especially in engineering
because they're so useful and applicable
and you can describe so many so many
phenomenon with vector calculus and in
kind of a coordinate system of dimension
2 or 3 okay so today
we're gonna be talking about we're gonna
be talking about div grad and curl okay
so the divergence the gradient and the
curl of a function or a vector field and
we're going to do it using this symbol
del or na blah
so the div is del dot grad is Del of and
curl is del cross F okay so I think
everybody is used this symbol del before
right yep okay and what I really want to
do today is a couple of things so so
these are extremely important linear
operators I say that they're linear
operators because they act like matrices
and vectors they they have the same
properties of linearity but what we're
going to find is that by writing
differential operators as a vector of
partial derivatives allows us to
generalize the concepts that were
familiar with of calculus to arbitrarily
high dimensional systems like we did for
OD ease and it's also going to allow us
to eventually solve essentially calculus
problems on manifolds okay when I say a
manifold I mean a geometry that's not
flat so if you want to study how
hurricanes move on the surface of the
earth you're fundamentally not going to
be working in a Cartesian coordinate
system you're going to be working on the
surface of the sphere and so you care
about what the normal vectors are and
you care about working in a coordinate
system that's actually relevant to that
spherical geometry in the example of the
double pendulum I care about these kind
of circular coordinates XY don't help me
very much but if I write my equations in
terms of theta 1 and theta 2 my
equations become much much simpler okay
and so what we're doing here is
essentially abstracting calculus to
vector spaces and eventually that's
going to allow us to abstract calculus
to
more general curved surfaces okay
very very powerful super applicable this
really opens up most of the problems in
classical mechanics that we would ever
want to solve okay okay so we're going
to mainly be working with this del
operator today so sometimes it's called
nabla how many of you have heard of
nabla right knob la is not quite as
common so knob la the funky homosapien
does not have quite the same ring to it
okay so del knob la and vectors of
partial derivatives how many of you
listen to the music of Deltron del the
funky homosapien no guerrillas yeah okay
so I have a hunch that that's where he
got his name okay so we're gonna define
this del operator as a vector of partial
derivatives so in the I direction we're
going to take the derivative with
respect to X in the J direction we're
going to take the derivative with
respect to Y and in the K direction
we're gonna take the derivative with
respect to Z or Z okay and we can of
course write this as a vector so anytime
we see this ijk coordinate directions we
can write this as a vector where this is
in the x position this is in the Y
position and this is in the Z position
so we have partial partial X partial
partial Y and partial partial Z okay now
this is pretty cool because we've
written this operator so I'm calling it
an operator because it operates on
functions or vector fields and it
operates in a linear way which is nice
so this operator Dell can be written as
a vector and so I can do anything with
this operator that I can do with a
vector I can take the dot product I can
multiply it by numbers I can multiply it
by matrices
I can take the cross-product and all of
those things okay so when I say that
this is a linear operator that means
something really special and something
really specific so Dell is a linear
operator because if I have for example
grad of F plus G so I have some function
f in some function G and I'm going to
take the gradient of it then that's
equal to the gradient of F plus the
gradient of G for all possible F and G
and I also have that gradient of some
number times F is just that number times
the gradient of F ok so here after n G
are functions of so f is a function of
XY and Z G is a function of XY and Z and
alpha is a number okay so the fact that
these two properties are true for all
functions F and G and for all numbers
alpha means that this del or gradient
operator is a linear operator okay so
what are some other examples of linear
operators that we've seen before
okay the derivative is definitely a
linear operator because if I take the
derivative I mean this is essentially a
vector of derivative so that so we're
building this on the fact that the
derivative is also a linear operator
true so the really really important one
is matrix multiplication okay
matrix multiplication or multiplication
by a matrix a can be thought of as a
linear operator okay so if I have a
matrix a then a operates on things that
multiplies vectors and gives you new
vectors okay so a is an operator and a
happens to be a linear operator because
a times vector 1 plus vector 2 is the
same thing as a times vector 1 plus a
times vector 2 okay so matrix
multiplication is kind of the classic or
most intuitive example of a linear
operator okay and so the idea is
anything we can do with matrices
everything you've learned from linear
algebra like getting orthogonal
directions and basis sets and
gram-schmidt and solving equations you
can do with other more general linear
operators and this gives us a nice way
of thinking about these calculus
problems in terms of linear operator
theory okay and this is gonna be really
really important when we solve partial
differential equations because when our
partial differential equation is only
written in terms of these linear
operators it's gonna be way way easier
to solve like those are the partial and
an ordinary differential equations we
can solve our systems like X dot equals
a times X we can solve this because any
times X is a linear operator and so my
solutions superpose my e to the lambda
1t and my either the lambda 2 t and all
of my e to the lambda T's I can just add
up those solutions and there's still a
solution in my system that's because of
the linearity of matrix multiplication
okay so linearity is a super super
important
property of this gradient operator and
have derivatives and this is something
we're going to revisit a little bit
later okay so so this is my del operator
del is just a vector of partial
derivatives and the first thing we're
gonna do to this this operator is we're
going to multiply it by a scalar
function okay a scalar field essentially
so so if we have the gradients then the
gradient is defined as applying this
linear operator to a scalar function f
okay so this linear operator applied to
some f of XY and Z is called the
gradients
does anyone know why this is called the
gradient why this is a good name sorry
yeah exactly if I thought of as a
contour map like maybe this is the
topography of Washington State and the
coordinates were just x and y then this
gradient would be how steep that you
know that contour surface was how steep
the mountains are in the X and the y
directions okay so it kind of measures
how fast my function is changing in
these different directions that's the
the gradients okay and so we say that
grad F is just partial F partial X
partial F partial Y and partial F
partial Z so this is kind of cool
we took a scalar function this is just a
number for every point XY and Z and
we've now defined this vector of the
gradient of s and this vector could
define a vector field we could integrate
a know de using this right hand side
this vector field which we did before
right when in a gravitation we said
force equals minus grad potential and
then we said well force equals mass
times X double dot okay so that's the
same gradient that we're talking about
here we can take a scalar function like
my mountain height and then using the
gradient I can tell how fast a ball will
roll down that height by integrating
this so de ok super useful before we
talked about really really simple toy
examples like a bead on a 1d hoop or a
1d wire but now we can start thinking
about things like you know this thing
could actually be a two-dimensional
surface right
and we can write the gradient of that
two-dimensional surface and then we can
get a multi-dimensional gradient field
and we can integrate that OTE okay
questions before we do an example okay
so this is probably mostly review but I
really want us to get the fundamentals
and I also want us to say this in the
language that we're going to be using
later so we might not have all heard
about this in the language of vector
spaces and so I think that's important
to kind of go through these these
examples starting from scratch so one
example is a mass in a gravitational
field okay and the gravitational field
is just a very very special type of
potential field okay so where do we
start with a gravitational potential
problem what is kind of the ground floor
what's the ground truth of gravitation
that we start with
okay so masses will accelerate in a
gravitational field but how what what
what makes them accelerate forces okay
what kinds of forces do we have in a
gravitational problem okay attraction so
we always start with Newton's universal
law of gravitation as long as our masses
are not extremely large or extremely
small right so for everything within ten
orders
maybe not ten seven orders of magnitude
in either direction of our masses we can
use Newton's law of gravity okay so we
have Newton's law and that law says that
the force that I feel force is a vector
right because it points in a direction
so this force is equal to minus little m
times Big M times G divided by radius
cubed in the radial direction so I'm
writing it in terms of a vector so
little m is the mass of my object big m
let's say that this is the mass of earth
and G is the universal or at least
approximately universal gravitational
constant then you would know if this is
still a constant so constants and
physics are always subject to change
with new data has anyone ever shown that
this is different anywhere okay let's
say it's still a constant you could
equally well think about this as the
gravitational field of an asteroid with
a spacecraft landing on it okay in fact
this is exactly the kind of vector
calculus that was just done to land a
spacecraft on an asteroid you have to
compute this nasty force field because
this thing is not a sphere but we're
going to assume that earth is a sphere
and this problem becomes a lot simpler
so this is a little different than what
we're used to because we have a divided
by R cubed but we know that the
gravitational attraction force is
proportional to inverse of our
squared so where is that extra are
coming from why do I have an R cubed
here right so my R vector also has a
magnitude of R okay so if I'm in the
direction R I need to normalize our and
then my forces the magnitude of my force
is proportional to 1 over R squared okay
and we've kind of already looked at this
before that this is equal to minus the
gradient of some potential field
potential energy field okay and we're
gonna say the gravitational potential
it's my favorite abbreviation is pop
just love that abbreviation okay so we
have this gravitational potential v
equals minus and mg over R and this is
just a scalar field for any radius
you're at doesn't matter what direction
you're pointing this is what your
gravitational potential is okay just a
scalar field so this is a scalar now
this doesn't look like the gravitational
potential we used for the particle and a
bead the bead and I in a wire right what
is different between this potential
energy and the potential energy that we
kind of have done for this bead on a
wire
I had like a minor crisis this morning
when I was writing down these notes
because I wrote this down and then I
wrote down the bead on a wire and there
were different potentials why are these
different potential energies they're
both in Earth's gravitational fields
well so as long as our radius so
essentially whenever we do a problem
like the bead on a wire
we are linearizing about the Earth's
radius
okay we're kind of linearizing this
gravitational potential about earth
radius which as far as this experiment
is concerned I'm experiencing the exact
same gravitational attraction if I'm one
meter higher or 1 meter lower it's
negligible the change in Earth's
attraction due to my 1 meter increase or
decrease of radius and so I linearized
this gravitational potential about
radius plus you know essentially you can
linearize about earth radius call that R
0 and so if you take this function 1
over R and linearize it about let's say
we're at 1 over r plus h and linear as
this about our not you'll get the
typical gravitational potential that
we're all used to seeing which is MGH
okay just something to keep in mind that
when we talk about you know kind of
earth sized distances we have to use
this gravitational potential when we
talk about lab experiments we're talking
about a linearized potential okay okay
so we have this earth can't really draw
earth there's part of it and we know
that all of the directions point in to
earth so this is essentially the force
field that we're experiencing and we
also know that the magnitude is smaller
the farther out you are okay so that's
one of the things we know about this pet
potential so what we can do is we can
take minus gradient of V and essentially
compute the XY and z components of this
gravitational velocity field and I'm
gonna write my radius like this I wanna
say it's minus M times big mg
over the square root of x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared so I'm making
life way more difficult for myself by
choosing Cartesian coordinates for
something that should definitely be
written in spherical coordinates but
we'll talk about spherical gradients
later in another lecture okay so we're
just kind of getting a feel for how to
do this so first we take partial V
partial X and that equals something
nasty like - little M big mg times 2 X
divided by 1/2 x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared to the three-halves power
these one has cancel and my negatives
cancel and I get something like this if
you take the partial derivative of V
with respect to X you get this
fortunately this denominator is actually
simple this is just radius cubed ok so
it looks nasty but it's not that bad we
just get a radius cubed in the
denominator partial V partial Y is the
same thing M big mg Y over radius cubed
partial V partial Z is little M big M G
Z over radius cubed ok and so our force
vector which is minus grad V excuse name
is equal to this in the I Direction plus
this in the J direction Plus this in the
k direction ok that's what my gradient
means and so this equals
this vector field okay so now for every
point in space for every x y&z location
you can name in the universe or in the
near-earth universe at least this is the
gravitational force vector and it points
into the center of Earth at all points
it points to the center of Earth okay so
this is essentially one way of deriving
the force vector field from the
gravitational potential using the
gradients and it's pretty
straightforward you just take partial
derivatives and stack them in a vector
okay and if you plot this in something
like MATLAB you'll find that you get
exactly what you expect you get all
arrows pointing into the center of the
earth they're stronger the closer you
are they're smaller the farther away you
are okay okay any questions about their
gradient you can use the gradient for
optimization like let's say I have some
cost function J of X let's make it a
little more complicated x and y so I
have this bowl okay so I have some cost
function J as a function of x and y and
it's just this parabolic dish or Bowl
okay if I want to find the minimum cost
values for x and y what I'm trying to
find our values of x and y that make my
partial derivatives equal to zero okay
so I want partial J partial X to equal
zero and I want partial J partial Y to
equal zero this will be true at my
optimum minimum point of this cost
function okay so optimization is one of
the most important fields of all of
applied mathematics I almost can
guarantee you that
some point in your careers you'll all do
optimization at some point of something
and the simplest and most kind of
intuitive type of optimization is called
the gradient optimization and this is
based on Newton's method of finding
zeros of a function so essentially we're
trying to find zeros of the gradient of
J so we want grad J to equal zero
okay and the way we do that is we start
at some point and we look at what the
gradient is and where it's pointing and
we take a step in that direction and
then I look at where the gradient is now
and it's now pointing this way so I take
a step in that direction and now I look
at where my gradient is pointing and I
take a step and I keep kind of walking
towards this optimum point and so using
Newton's method on the gradient of J you
can walk towards an optimal solution
this is called a gradient descent search
and it's the most popular mathematical
optimization technique but again it's
built on the gradient and it totally
generalizes if I had 15 variables I
could still do a gradient search I just
need to compute this 15 dimensional
vector of partial derivatives with
respect to each of my coordinate
directions okay we will talk about
optimization a little bit more this is a
really really important idea in data
science and so we'll probably talk about
this more in 565 okay good so now I want
to tell you about the divergence so that
was the gradient gradients really
important today I'm going to try to get
through div grad and curl and then in
the next lecture we're going to talk
about the conservation laws and kind of
integral calculus theorems like the
divergence theorem and the Stokes
theorem and greens theorem okay because
these are super important
okay so now we're gonna talk about
divergence so what's the physical
intuition about a divergence what is the
divergence mean physically for a vector
field maybe I should write it down first
I'll think about this while I write it
down okay so with the gradient we saw
that we could take a scalar function
it's just F of XY and Z and when we took
the gradient it became a vector field
okay so for every point XY and Z I now
get a vector and it points in the
direction of the gradient of F so since
del is a vector I can take the inner
product also but what do I need to take
the inner product with another vector
alright I need another vector so
essentially with a vector F okay so
let's say that I have my vector f of XY
and Z and it equals f1 of XY and z f2 of
XY and Z and F 3 of x y&z ok so now I
have a more complicated function still a
function of space XY and Z but now at
each point in space I have a vector so
this is a vector field and in fact it
could have been a vector field obtained
by taking the gradient of some scalar
function right no reason not to so the
divergence is Del dot F the dot product
of my gradient operator over of my del
operator with this vector field is the
divergence
okay and this is just a number anytime I
take the dot product of two vectors I
get a number out so before I took the
gradient of a number and I got a vector
now I'm taking the divergence of a
vector and I'm getting a number okay so
what this looks like if I take the dot
product of my vector partials with this
F I just get del dot F equals partial F
1 partial X plus partial F 2 partial y
plus partial F 3 partial Z just a number
ok now what is this intuitively or
physically mean this divergence how many
of you study fluids a little bit ok
only a couple so the divergence measures
whether or not my vector field is
expanding or contracting or keeping
volumes the same ok so the divergence
literally measures how much particles in
this vector field will diverge ok or
converge or not move at all with respect
to each other
okay so we're just going to do this on
three examples and this will really
clearly paint the picture of physically
what this is doing okay so example one
is this vector F equals x in the I
Direction plus Y in the J direction so
we're dealing with a two dimensional
system so my del is partial partial X
partial partial Y okay and so div dot F
is just partial of this term with
respect to X plus partial of this term
with respect to Y which is just one plus
one okay so this equals two that makes
sense yeah okay so this is a positive
divergence and if I plot this vector
field what it looks like is okay so
let's pick x equals one y equals zero
then my F is pointing in the positive
one direction let's pick x equals two
and y equals zero then my vector is
pointing in the positive two directions
so it's increasing in magnitude as I go
away
same thing with Y and both of these so
in all directions this thing is kind of
expanding outward and accelerating as it
goes okay a positive divergence means
essentially that my flow field is
diverging that's why it's called
divergence this is written by people who
spoke a language and they picked a word
that meant the same thing is what this
actually does okay so that's what the
divergence does let's try another
example so example two let's make a
field that points inward same field
except I'm going to put negative signs F
equals minus X in the
direction- why in the J direction so
what's this divergence - - del dot F
equals -2 and what does this vector
field look like all of my arrows are
pointing in and they point in faster the
farther away I am alright so same deal
okay
so if I have if I have the positive
divergence then this is essentially
saying that the flow is diverging here
we can say that the flow is converging
so negative divergence the opposite of
divergence is convergence okay and then
we're going to look at a final example
example 3 which is my vector function f
equals minus y in the I Direction plus X
in the J direction okay should we
compute the curl the divergence first or
should we plot it first plot which one
I heard compute the divergence first
let's compute the divergence first okay
so how do i compute this divergence of F
what's the first thing I do
okay I take partial partial X of the I
components so partial Y partial X is
zero plus partial of the J component
with respect to Y which is also 0 so
this divergence is zero what that
picture looks like is the following so
let's say that I am at a point x equals
1 y equals 0 so I'm at this point where
does my vector point now like where it
is my function f point at x equals 1 y
equals 0 so in the positive J Direction
right because I have one in the J
direction so I've got a 1 here similarly
if I was at x equals negative 1 I would
have a down in the J direction like
that's how we read off this vector
function if I had y equals 1 and x
equals 0 I would be pointing in a
negative direction like this and
similarly in the positive direction for
y equals minus 1 ok and so I get this
kind of rotational flow so this is a
pure rotation in fact this is what we
got when we solved that differential
equation if I solved x and y dots equals
0 Omega minus Omega 0 of x and y I would
get this vector field it's the same
vector field basically as this
differential equation ok so what it
means when divergence is 0 is that this
flow is neither expanding nor
contracting we say that it's
incompressible you can't make its volume
smaller you also can't make volumes
larger so we say flow is incompressible
at least that's what we say in fluids
and there's probably other can term
terms in in elastics I think you would
call this the continuity equation so I
want to just draw this as a picture
because I think this makes a little more
sense so imagine that I started with
some initial
Blob in each of these locations of a
certain volume okay what happens to this
blue blob in this diverging flow right
all of those let's say I literally just
this is a fluid flow like it when you
turn your sink on in your faucet sorry
when you turn your faucet on in your
sink water comes down and it creates
this expanding flow outward and if you
put a little bit of blue dye in the sink
what is it gonna do it's gonna go
outward and it's going to expand in
volume okay so it's going to end up here
now what about this example this is like
if I have my bathtub full of water and I
pull the plug now all the water is
coming in towards the center so this is
a sink and if I have this initial blue
dye it's going to get converged into a
smaller volume okay and this blue dye is
essentially just going to be rotated but
it's going to stay in the same shape and
it's also going to stay in the same size
okay this is like if I had some object
in a vortex in a tornado or a hurricane
okay these are essentially you can think
of these as the same vector fields that
are being defined from our ordinary
differential equations before okay so
it's really there's a pretty strong
connection from vector calculus to
ordinary differential equations okay any
questions about the divergence okay
so finally we're going to talk about the
curl so why are there just three of
these operators div grad and curl that
we normally talk about
because this del operator is in
essentially a vector space it's a linear
operator on vector valued functions and
we have dot products and cross products
and that's those are kind of the
essential ingredients for these inner
product spaces so if you had extra
structure for an extra special vector
space that you invented you could define
a new operation with Dell that would be
fine so the curl of my vector field F is
given by the cross product of Dell with
F and remember from the last lecture we
can take this vector Dell and whenever
we take the cross product of a vector we
can write that as a matrix okay so we
could write this as like there's no way
I'm gonna get this right let's say zero
minus partial partial Z partial partial
Y minus partial partial Y partial
partial Z zero minus partial partial X
partial partial X 0 right this is Del
cross I might have messed up the
negative signs I think this is right
I don't remember okay and so if we had
that same s as before that had F 1 F 2 F
3 then we can write the curl as curl
cross F is the determinant of this
matrix F 1 F 2 F 3 the three components
of F it's the same as multiplying this
by F
okay okay before we talk about what this
means let's do a super simple example
okay so if f equals XY in the I
Direction minus sign of Z in the J
direction plus one in the K direction
then I would plug in I'm just going to
plug in these components so f1 is x
times y f2 is minus sine of Z and F 3 is
just 1 just the constant 1 and so I can
take this to R if this determinant of my
del operator crossed with my F vector
and I get okay so in the I direction
what's partial partial y of 1 0 ok
partial partial Z so minus partial
partial z of sine is e so minus minus
coast of Z so I get 1 Coast Z ok in the
J direction so minus J times partial
partial X of 1 partial partial Z of x
times y also 0 no Z's in here so 0 in
the J direction and then in the K
direction I have partial partial X of
sine Z is 0 and partial partial Y of X Y
just X and there's a minus minus X so
curl of F is Coast Z in the I direction
minus X in the k direction ok easy to
take the curl of something you literally
just take f1 f2 f3 and you plug it into
the definition of the cross product
okay so there are some physical
interpretations of what the curl means
so the one of the most obvious
interpretations of curl is in fluids if
I have something rotating in the fluid
so the thing I just erased has a curl
because it has a rotational component of
the fluid so curl measures rotation in
my vector field whether or not particles
rotate or knots so it picks up vorticity
if I take the curl of my velocity field
then I get vorticity which is a measure
of how much things are spinning like
tornadoes have a ton of vorticity
hurricanes have a ton of work this week
another example is if I have some
rotating solid object like an asteroid
okay so let's say I'm trying to land on
an asteroid and this thing is rotating
about some vector W and the length of W
is its rotational rate Omega and if I am
looking at some point at some radius
from the origin then we know that W
cross R is that points velocity okay so
the velocity of any point in this
asteroid that's rotating is given by
curl of the rotation vector with the
radius vector from the axis of rotation
of that point okay and if I take the
curl of this vector field V I'll find
that curl V equals to Omega so the curl
of V measures twice my rotational speed
at all points so this is in the notes
you can work through this kind of more
carefully and actually show that this
really is 2 Omega but what I'm getting
at is that the curl
Rolle measures rotation the curl of a
vector field measures rotation and
fluids and solid bodies in any system if
you have rotation in your vector field
the curl pulls out the rotation
divergence pulls out expansion and
contraction curls pull out rotation okay
that's the the geometric interpretation
okay that's all I have time for today in
the next lecture we're going to talk
about the vector calculus theorems like
divergence theorem Gauss's theorem
Stokes theorem things like that okay